you
the day begins in dark ooh with the
arrival of the morning school boat the
children live on outlying islands in the
rail River Delta lessons will begin soon
a drumbeat signals the start of school
today's lesson plan includes civics
don't wait for others to do something
for you think instead about how you can
be useful to the community what are you
on about otherwise you're a silly as
breadfruit community is important here
in dark ooh a tiny village in the
southeast of Fiji's main island viti
levu the 400 some villagers have a
common problem it has become nearly
impossible to grow anything here as a
result of climate change the river rises
on a regular basis and floods half the
village that's why our houses are on
stilts the brackish water rises from
below we can't plant vegetables because
everything dies right away it's become
more extreme over the past eight years
not at all relatives I recently a dam
was built to protect the village it was
paid for with government and
international aid without here we might
have been forced to move away we want to
save the village for our children and
grandchildren so lukela gorillas but how
can the village sustain itself the women
of dark who have found an answer and
simultaneously sparked a revolution for
generations they've been weaving fans
out of palm fronds their technique is a
well-kept secret alumina thrown away is
underlain okay it's something sacred a
privilege that was granted to us by
vaniville ooh Fiji's first king we
weren't ever allowed to sell the fans
but now with climate change and the
economic problems are men requested
permission from the king and for the
past few years we've been allowed to
sell them
the fans are sold for about 3 euros each
and now account for nearly seventy
percent of dark whose income financially
the men of dark ooo are now almost
completely dependent on the women it's a
major change in their lives until
recently women and younger villagers had
little say the Fiji Islands are still
largely a male-dominated society that's
abundantly clear at the several server
ceremony only men get to drink the
coveted kava root grog it's bitter numbs
the mouth and it's considered a real
delicacy the drink is also said to be
healthy the woven fan initiative hasn't
led to greater social upheaval in the
village thanks to a gender equality
training program financed with German
funding villagers attended workshops
where they learned that they could solve
their economic problems better if the
men and women work together as equals
the women's representative tries to
ensure that the lesson isn't forgotten
but not everyone in the village is happy
when the bastions of male dominance are
threatened the school manager a
respected member of the community airs
his complaints gender for me gender has
nothing to do with equality the man
should make the decisions not the woman
we know that from the Bible the woman
should obey and serve the man that's the
natural god-given order and that
shouldn't change the men here have
fished in the rail River Delta for
generations
these mangrove swamps were once swarming
with fish and shrimp
but in many areas deforestation has led
to riverbank erosion the water contains
more sediment the sealed clogs the
mangroves and destroys the fish breeding
places the fishermen see the effects
every time they take their boats out the
catch in the fish traps is meager so the
men now regularly make trips to the
fertile island of kalili to collect palm
leaves for the fans everything that
grows is considered common property Oh
to get us younger I bring coconuts to
eat back from the plantation and
branches that are used to make the fans
that's become our most important source
of income dunno I'm a will need up your
motherboard it's a well-organized supply
system that gives the men of dark ooh
the opportunity to contribute to the
villagers success they also help Boyle
the Front's from the coconut palms no
Arnie as husband of the woman's
representative it's my job to support my
wife oh I see to the firewood in the
water where and I'm very proud that she
has this important decision boy I'm glad
you recognized my word such examples of
mutual respect and not to be taken for
granted in Fiji meanwhile in dokku the
villages have gathered for a celebration
the highlight is the Miki dance faces
and bodies are blackened with charcoal
here at least the young men of the
village can carry on male traditions
just like they did a hundred years ago